well switching gears voting is now open  this morning john and the animal  foundation's best in show  yeah so now through friday you could go  online and pick your favorite canine in  three different categories  voting is free tickets though for the  crowning  that costs 20 bucks and it is coming up  on sunday morning alex oh look how cute  these guys are  every one of these dogs will be  available for adoption  the shelter has moved the event online  of course this year as we told you  because of the pandemic  but you can still see the dogs you can  still vote for him  and then you can take him home and in  this election there is no uh there's no  issues of recounts or anything like that  there are no allegations of any  malpractice here you can vote as much as  you like and have some fun with it yes  some good news  6 27 here on a tuesday morning